usted o alguien que usted quiere puede
haber sido diagnosticado con cáncer de
próstata este vídeo le ayudará a
entender algunas de las principales
opciones de tratamiento disponibles
el cáncer de próstata es un tipo de
cáncer que se forma en la próstata del
hombre la mayoría de los tumores de
próstata que deseen lentamente en
comparación con otros tipos de cáncer
usted y su médico decidirán su
tratamiento basados en varios factores
estos factores incluyen la calificación
y etapa de su cáncer
su salud y su historial médico
y su edad
puede haber otros factores que sean
importantes para usted y su familia
los tratamientos para el cáncer de
próstata incluyen vigilancia activa
cirugía de próstata tome a
radioterapia
y terapia hormonal
e inmunoterapia
y la vigilancia activa significa
frecuentes visitas al médico para
vigilar de cerca cualquier crecimiento o
cambios en la próstata durante estas
visitas el médico palpar a la próstata
mediante la inserción de un dedo
enguantado en el recto esto se llama un
examen rectal digital
además se le hará un análisis de sangre
para revisar el nivel de una sustancia
en la sangre llamada psa los hombres con
cáncer de próstata a menudo tienen un
nivel más alto de psa en la sangre
a veces la vigilancia activa significa
que su médico tomara una biopsia de la
próstata
durante una biopsia el médico extraerá
muestras de tejido de la próstata a
través del recto con una aguja
es posible que tenga que someterse a una
operación llamada prostatectomía para
extirparle la próstata
otro tratamiento llamado terapia de
radiación utiliza la radiación para
reducir los tumores y matar las células
cancerosas en la radioterapia de 'las
externo una máquina dirige la radiación
hacia la próstata desde fuera del cuerpo
por el contrario la radiación de 'las
interno utiliza material radioactivo
colocado dentro del tumor
la terapia hormonal es otro tratamiento
para el cáncer de próstata
afecta a ciertas sustancias producidas
por el cuerpo llamadas hormonas el
cáncer de próstata necesita estas
hormonas para crecer los medicamentos
para la terapia hormonal pueden prevenir
el crecimiento del cáncer de dos maneras
en primer lugar los fármacos pueden
bloquear la acción de una o más hormonas
de la próstata en segundo lugar los
fármacos pueden bloquear o reducir la
cantidad de hormonas producidas por el
cuerpo la inmuno oncología también
conocida como inmunoterapia ayuda a su
sistema inmunitario a combatir el cáncer
por ejemplo un tratamiento utiliza
ciertas células inmunitarias de su
cuerpo estas células se cultivan en el
laboratorio y se les administra una
vacuna que las hace más activas luego
las células inmunitarias activadas se
devuelven a su cuerpo para ayudar a
atacar las células cancerosas
su médico puede prescribir otros
tratamientos distintos a los descritos
aquí
hablé con su médico si tiene preguntas
acerca de su medicación o si presenta
efectos secundarios
asegúrese de tomar sus medicamentos
según las indicaciones de su médico